لقد قلت شيئًا عن منظمة أطباء
بلا حدود وأنه تم
تجنيدهم من قبل حماس، وقلت إن هذا صحيح، هل
تم تجنيد اليونسكو من قبل حماس
سور أو اليونيسيف بدلاً من ذلك، هل تم
تجنيد اليونيسف من قبل حماس، لقد
أصبح الثلاثة جميعًا أصواتًا
لحماس لا شيء  منهم لديهم أي مصداقية
في جميع أنحاء العالم في الأشخاص الموضوعيين ومن
ليس لديه من لم يتم تجنيده من قبل
H إذا كنت لا تمانع في قولي والآن
نرى حركة المناخ تلك
الشابة من السويد
الناطقة بلسان حماس ولكن فقط لأنه
العالم يدين أه كثيرون في
العالم يدينون إسرائيل هذا لا يعني أن
إسرائيل مخطئة إسرائيل ليست مثالية
ولكن مقارنة بحماس أه حماس هي
أعظم شر
يواجهه الشعب الفلسطيني على الإطلاق وإذا
دمرت حماس شعب فلسطين
سأكون مسرورًا وسعيدًا جدًا لأن حماس
لأن غزة كان من الممكن أن تكون سنغافورة
في البحر الأبيض المتوسط ​​عندما غادرتها إسرائيل
أريد أن أطرح بعض الأسئلة إذا كنت
لا تمانع أهل الصديق سأسألك
عن إسرائيل أه أه من المفترض أن
تغادر في عام 2005  لكن أريد فقط أن أسأل
مرة أخرى لقد أخبرتني الآن أن أه أطباء
بلا حدود أن اليونيسيف وحتى
حركات المناخ تم تجنيدهم من قبل
حماس أو أنهم متحدثون باسم حماس
حسنًا من لم يتم تجنيده من قبل حماس
مثل من من في الخاص  وجهة النظر لها
مصداقية، هل السابق أه هل يفعل
المدعي العام المؤسس للمحكمة الجنائية الدولية، لويس مورينو
كامبو، هل تم تجنيده من قبل حماس
أيضًا أم أنه شخص يتمتع
بمصداقية لا لا لا، لويس كومبو هو
صديق جيد لي لقد علمنا معًا
في كلية الحقوق، هل يمكنني ذلك؟  أقتبس منه شيئا
فهو أعرف ما قاله وأنا لا أتفق
معه ولكن لديه مصداقية
أعتقد عموما المصداقية ولكن الكثير
من هذه المنظمات الأخرى لا أه
وزارة الخارجية الأمريكية لديها
مصداقية بريطانيا العظمى لديها
مصداقية أه بعض
الدول الأوروبية الأخرى  أه مصداقية
ألمانيا لديها مصداقية ولكن منظمة أطباء
بلا حدود لا تملك ذلك ولكن دعنا نصل إلى ذلك
ولكن أردت أن أقول شيئًا إذا كنت
لا تمانع فقط دعنا نجعل الأمر في
اتجاهين قليلاً فقط إذا كنت لا تمانع كذلك كما
أنا  ذكر هناك أمبو أومبو الذي كان
المدعي العام المؤسس
للمحكمة الجنائية الدولية يقول الحصار على غزة
حتى قبل 7 أكتوبر وقبل ما
نشهده الآن حسنا هذه
كلماته الحصار على غزة هو شكل من أشكال
الإبادة الجماعية لأنه يفرض
الظروف  أنه لم يفعل ذلك، أنا أقتبس
أنا أقتبس منك كلمة بكلمة ويمكننا أن
نلعبها، قال هذا الاقتباس بعد أن قال
هذا بعد 7 أكتوبر وليس قبل 7
أكتوبر، لقد سمح لي بتوضيح الأمر حسنًا،
كان يتحدث عن ما بعد 7 أكتوبر  لقد
ضللت وجهة نظرك تمامًا، دعني
وما سنفعله هو أننا
سنلعب هذا بالفعل سنعزف هذا سنعزف هذا لنسمعه،
حصار جاسا نفسه
الذي يمثل إبادة أو اضطهادًا باعتباره
CRI ضد الإنسانية وهو شكل من أشكال
المادة 6 ج أو 2 ج من الإبادة الجماعية في
اتفاقية الإبادة الجماعية حدد أنك
لا تحتاج إلى قتل الناس لارتكاب
إبادة جماعية، حيث تنص القاعدة على فرض
شروط لتدمير المجموعة التي
تعتبر في حد ذاتها إبادة جماعية، لذا فإن إنشاء
الحصار بحد ذاته هو نوع من الإبادة الجماعية  هذا
واضح جدًا، إسرائيل والحصار
واضح جدًا ونوايا تدمير
الشعب، والعديد من ضباط
الحكومة الإسرائيلية يعبرون عن نوايا الإبادة الجماعية، ولهذا
السبب من السهل القول
والمعقول أن نعتقد أن إسرائيل
ترتكب إبادة جماعية في
غزة